Nicole is with us in Waldorf from
Maryland hi Nicole how are you better
than I deserve what's up
great I'm so glad you receive my call
well I'm calling because I'm a single
parent I am divorced now for several
years I was just calling because I have
a lot of debt and I really don't know
where to start with this debt because
I'm not of the debt it's priority I'd be
it listed if you want those numbers so I
can give them to you
well my total debt is one hundred and
ninety one thousand dollars including my
house how much of that your house one
hundred and nineteen thousand dollars
seven thousand dollars of it is credit
card even thousand dollars as taxes our
own taxes for the last tax years
why because I needed my money during a
year so if I'm a single parent I have a
senior at college and I have a current
PLUS loan and then I had so you didn't
pay your taxes I paid some of my taxes I
didn't pay enough enough didn't go in
now are you selling
no okay what other debts have you got
twenty two thousand dollars is for a TSP
loan two thousand dollars is a pleasure
and then the 119 thousand for my
mortgage but I did refinance my mortgage
to a fifteen year and I make my payments
how much I'm company I don't have a car
payment right my car my car right now is
on its last leg I bought it brand new at
2009 nine years I make ninety eight
thousand dollars Wow wonderful what are
you doing for a living
work for the federal government I'm a
trencher okay great
and you have one child and he's in
college I have one daughter that's in
college she's a senior then I have
another daughter she's a junior in high
school but she goes to a Christian
school and I have to pay tuition for her
every month mm-hmm okay so that's
another death but that's very important
to me the Christian education mm-hmm
okay
and she's a junior in high school yes
how much of how much of your older
daughter are you paying for the college
well I have a thirty two thousand dollar
prize yeah I got that but I mean are you
paying more is this kid the kid in
college isn't what ain't what your in
college she's a senior okay so are you
done with that I'll be done this year
with more loans or as I said no this is
it okay well the first step to getting
out of debts quit borrowing all right
you can't borrow more you can't get out
of a hole while digging out the bottom I
understand listening to you about two
weeks now and I was able to get together
the money for my baby start $100,000
don't you I'm just trying to figure out
what to do with the rest the second step
is to get yourself on a budget jump on
every dollar calm and get your budget
going you make good money your house
payment is not that high you don't have
a car payment so you're in pretty good
shape there and then you start looking
at that budget and saying okay I'm not
gonna see the inside of a restaurant
unless I'm working there is an extra job
we're not going on vacation I don't have
any money you see the thing about
hitting goals it's not what you're
willing to do to hit your goals that
causes should hit them it's what you're
willing to give up to hit your goals and
right now what happens is is that you
see something you want to do and you
just go do it and then you look up and
go won't earn there's an 11
dollars and debt on taxes oh there's a
thirty two thousand dollar debt in
college you know now what are we gonna
do in this scene this kid in high school
gets very girlf college would another
forty thousand dollars in debt no yes I
haven't been able to say for my youngest
daughter's college so well what do I do
now well she's a junior well she's gonna
have to go to a college that's cheap
number one number two she's gonna be
working while she's in college number
three you may have an extra job during
this time while you're paying off a
bunch of these other debts you sure as
crap can't not pay your taxes anymore
that was suicidal I agree and I did
change my dependents to zero so they're
taking the max out of my paycheck well I
don't want to have the proper amount
taken out and then get the eleven
thousand dollars paid as fast as you can
and then I want you to cut up your
credit cards and we've got to have a
plan for this kid to go to college I
love that she's in a Christian education
and I love that that means something to
you and I think you can probably work
that out
I don't know how expensive it is but if
you have to choose between her going to
that school her senior year or her going
to college which would you choose
you might have to judge yeah you might
have to choose it'd be very painful for
her to movers senior year of high school
emotionally that would be a horrible
thing I hope that doesn't have to happen
how expensive is this Christian school
ten thousand four hundred dollars a year
so that's like eight hundred and sixty
eight dollars a month
yeah that's not that's not killing you
that's not about ten percent of your
income so that's not gonna you know if
you told me thirty thousand we'd have to
talk about this you know ten thousand is
I think you can probably make this so
number one when you start doing a budget
you're gonna feel like you got a raise
every month you make every dollar behave
you are now happening to your money
instead of your money happening to you
you can do this Nicole I've been talking
to you for five minutes you're not a
dumb person you're a smart person you
can do this but you you've kind of just
kind of wandered along and this stuff
has all happened to you and now you're
gonna happen
it and it's gonna be like a Corral it's
gonna be like a ground you got a sweet
little voice and I want to hear a growl
in your voice like I'm getting out of
that okay my divorce it was like I was
just hit with a lot of death yeah at
once and that's not the problem stuff
you're facing today you did it they won
the war okay you took out the 32,000
Parent PLUS loan you didn't pay the
taxes and you ran those credit cards up
that's okay I've done you know I've done
a lot of stupid stuff in my life
you're not dumbest I might talk to
you're pretty smart I think you can do
this but you're gonna have to really cut
your lifestyle to nothing and it has to
be a thing you focus on and in it to the
exclusion of almost anything else really
I got two goals I got three goals in
this call that I want to try to do all
three of them and if that means I work
two extra jobs I'm gonna do it if I'm in
your shoes number one goal is I wanna
start working on getting out of debt
number two goal is I want to keep this
kid in that school if I can and number
three goal is we want her to go to
college and pay cash for it but if she's
going to a cheap school not an expensive
one unless somebody else is paying for
it because her mother is a broke single
mom that's a hundred and ninety thousand
dollars in debt and she doesn't need to
run up a bunch of student loans herself
either yes ma'am I'm in the TSP but all
of it is gone and I have it in the G
fund and I've done the wrong thing by
having all of it going through the
g-shot yeah I will have it all in the
sea I'll defeat 80% percent in the sea
ten percent in the eye ten percent in
the ass but I wouldn't have anything
going in there right now until you clean
this mess up I will stop all investing
and temporarily because you got a TSP
loan you got a twenty dollar investment
five percent I'm addressing that for
sure only because others are for Santa
Claus horses there
stop don't put anything don't put
anything in there just pay the loans all
you're gonna do stop and I'm gonna show
you how to do all this I'm gonna put you
through our class our program called
Financial Peace University it's a
one-year membership I'm gonna pay for it
to sign you up for free the only thing I
ask is you go to all nine lessons at a
local church and then you stay in the
thing you stay online you stay in the
every dollar budget and when you get out
of debt you call me and tell me you're
doing it and if you need some help you
call me and I'll help you you can do
this Nicole you can do this this is the
Dave Ramsey show